Bootstrapping can really,
really test your soul in a lot of ways.
You have to have a thick,
thick skin because
people are going to tell you that
what you're doing isn't valuable or
they're not going to see your
perspective, so you have to have
resolute belief in your core goal for
you to be successful in this space.
Bootstrapping is often looked at as or
it can be looked at as you're crazy or
that's never going to work or
how could anybody find value in that.
You'll hear a lot of naysayers and I
think it's overcoming the mental games,
both externally and internally,
that are what makes bootstrapping hard.
You can't listen to the negative
voices that are are telling you
you can't do it.
If you've started off with
the belief that you can,
test that theory all the way through.
You owe it to yourself.